2020 a year many want to consign to
history
but with brexit on the horizon restoring
economic certainty to the country's
pandemic hit towns and cities
will be a challenge on the eve of
britain's divorce from the eu
in the port city of dover old questions
remain
is this really the right thing to do
it's got to be better we
we need to govern ourselves and be our
own bosses there's going to be a lot of
stress between everyone anyway because
it's
a very unknown and people don't deal
well with change
the uk left the eu legally at the end of
january
but remained subject to its rules while
it negotiated new arrangements
a deal now in place people will start to
see what brexit really means
it could be years before some changes
are felt the agreement on reducing the
eu's access to british fishing grounds
only lasts five years and will need
renegotiating
our decisions still have to be made on
financial services and data sharing
there won't be any new taxes to pay on
exports at the border
but there'll be plenty of red tape and
possible delays
everyday freedoms will also end with new
rules on
travel immigration mobile phone use bank
accounts the list goes on
and there are profound implications for
the future of the united kingdom
brexit's reignited scotland's
independence debate
the scottish nationalist parties called
brexit an unforgivable
act of economic vandalism promising to
restore
eu membership to largely pro-eu scotland
if it becomes independent northern
ireland
is the only part of the uk that will
continue to follow many of the eu's
rules
to avoid the return of a contentious
hard border with eu member of the
republic of ireland
but that means new checks on goods
entering northern ireland from the rest
of the uk
unionists who want to retain seamless
ties with britain
now fear being cut off i think the deal
has made northern ireland a place apart
we wanted to come out of the european
union the same terms as the rest of the
united kingdom
sadly that didn't happen for four and a
half years
brexit convulsed british politics
polarizing the country
dividing families even the father of
british prime minister boris johnson
has announced he's in the process of
applying for a french passport
to retain ties with the eu all of this
does of course mean that we might start
to hear the word brexit just a little
less
but deep divisions and fierce passions
remain
whether or not brexit drives or
diminishes the british economy we know
it's going to happen and in one last
stroke of irony
it will be at midnight brussels time not
midnight
british time that the changes will come
into force
the moment britain voluntarily
disconnects
from the world's largest trading bloc
neve barker al jazeera london